welcome back in this presentation I
actually want to show you how we can use
the antiderivative to figure out the
area under curve and hopefully actually
I want to focus more a little bit on the
intuition
so let's actually use an example from
physics I'll use distance and velocity
and actually this could be a good review
for derivatives or actually an
application of derivatives so let's say
that that I described the position of
something moving let's say it's s let's
say that s is equal to I don't know 16 T
squared right so s is distance let me
write this in the corner I don't know
why the convention is to use s as as the
variable for distance one would think
well actually I know why why won't they
use D because D is the is a letter used
for differential I guess so
s is equal to distance and then T is
equal to time so this is just a formula
that tells us the position kind of how
far has something gone after X many
let's say seconds right so after like
four seconds we would have gone let's
say the distance is in feet and this is
in seconds after four seconds we would
have gone to 256 feet that's all that
says and let me let me graph that as
well graph it okay that's a horrible
that was a horrible line let me have to
use the line tool might have better luck
it's slightly better actually let me
undo that too because I just want to do
it for positive T right because you
can't really go back in time or for the
purposes of this lecture lecture you
can't go back in time so that's good
that'll have to do
okay so this is this the curve this
curve will essentially just just be a
parabola right it'll look something like
this right so actually if you look at it
I mean you could just eyeball that the
that the object every second you go it's
going a little bit further right so it's
actually accelerating and so what if we
wanted to figure out what the velocity
of this
of this object right this is Lucy this
is D this is T right and this is I don't
know if it's clear but this is kind of
one half of a parabola so that's that
this is the distance function so what
would the velocity be well the velocity
is just what's velocity its distance
divided by time right and since this
velocity is always changing we want to
figure out the instantaneous velocity
and that's actually one of the initial
uses of what made a derivative so useful
so we want to find the change the
instant chain is changed with respect to
time of this formula right because this
is the distance formula so if we know
the instant rate of change of distance
with respect to time we'll know the
velocity right so DS D s DT is equal to
so what's the derivative here it's 3232
T right and this is the velocity
velocity maybe I should switch back to
well let me write that V equals velocity
I don't know why I switch colors but
I'll stick with the yellow so let's
graph this function this will actually
be a fairly straightforward graph to
draw oh no it's pretty straight and then
let me draw the x-axis
Vaman I'm doing pretty good okay and so
this I'll try it in red it's just going
to be a line right 32t it's a line with
slope 32 so it's actually a pretty steep
line I won't draw it that steep because
I'm going to use this for an
illustration so this is the velocity let
me let me so this is velocity this is
this is that graph and then this is
distance right so in case you hadn't
learned already and maybe I'll do a
whole presentation on kind of using
calculus for physics and using
derivatives for physics but if you have
the distance formula its derivative is
just velocity and I guess if you if you
view it the other way if you had the
velocity its antiderivative is distance
although you don't you won't know where
at what position the object started and
this in this case the position the optic
started at position of zero but it could
be you know at any constant right you
can started here and then curved up but
anyway let's just assume we started at
zero so the derivative of distance is
velocity the antiderivative of velocity
is distance keep that in mind well let's
look at this let's assume that we were
only given this this graph and we said
you know this is the graph of the
velocity of some object we and we want
to figure out what the distance is after
you know T seconds right so this is the
T axis and this is the velocity axis
right so let's say we were only given
this and let's say we didn't know that
the antiderivative of the velocity
function is the distance function how
would we figure out how would we figure
out what what the distance would be in
any given time well let's think about it
if if we have if we have a constant this
red is kind of bloody let me let me
switch to something more pleasant if we
have over any small period of time right
or if we have a constant velocity when
you have a constant velocity distance is
just velocity times time right so let's
say we had a very small time fragment
here right I'll draw it big but let's
say this time frame
is really small and let's call this very
small time fragment let's call this
delta T or DT actually the way I view of
DT is like it's like a change in time
that's unbelievably small right so it's
like almost instantaneous but not quite
or you can actually view it as
instantaneous so this is this is how
much time goes by you can kind of view
this as a very small change in time so
if we have a very small change of time
and over that very small change in time
we have a roughly constant velocity
let's say the roughly constant velocity
is this right this is the velocity so
see we had over this very small change
in time we have this roughly constant
velocity that's on this graph actually
let me take do it here we have this
roughly constant velocity so the
distance that the object travels over
the small time would be the small time
times the velocity right it would be
whatever the value of this red line is
times the width of this distance right
so what's another way visually I kind of
I kind of did it ahead of time but
what's happening here if I take this
this change in time right which is kind
of the base of this rectangle and I
multiply it times the velocity which is
really just the height of this rectangle
what have I figured out well I figured
out the area of this rectangle right
right the velocity this moment times the
change in time at this moon is nothing
but the area of this very skinny
rectangle skinny and tall right it's
almost infinitely skinny but it's we're
assuming for this these purposes it has
some very notional amount of width so
there we figured out the area of this
column right well if we wanted to figure
out the the distance that you travel
after let's say let's say you know I
don't know let's say T let's say T sub
naught right this is just a particular T
after T sub naught seconds right well
then all we would have to do is we would
have to just figure we would just do a
bunch of DT
these right you do another one here and
you'd figure out the height of the area
of this column you'd figure out the area
of this column the area of this column
right because each of these areas each
of the areas of each of these columns
represents the distance that the object
travels over that DT right so if you
wanted to know how far you traveled
after T sub zero seconds you would
essentially get or an approximation
would be the the sum of all of these
areas and as you got more and more if as
you made the DT smaller and smaller
skinnier and skinnier skinnier and you
had more and more and more and more of
these rectangles then your approximation
will get pretty close to well two things
it will get pretty close to as you can
imagine the area under this curve or in
this case a line but it would also get
you pretty much the the exact amount of
distance you've traveled after T sub
naught seconds so I think I'm running
into the the 10 minute the wall so I'm
just going to pause here and then I'm
going to continue this in the next
presentation